i remain gravely concerned about the  unfolding situation in and around  europe's largest nuclear power plant in  zaporizia  common sense must prevail to avoid any  actions that might endanger the physical  integrity safety or security of the  nuclear plant  and the facility must not be used as  part of any military operation  instead  agreement is urgently needed to  establish zaporizi as purely civilian  infrastructure and to ensure the safety  of the area military equipment and  personnel should be withdrawn from the  plant  further deployment of forces or  equipment to the site must be avoided  the area needs to be demilitarized  and we must tell it  as it is  any potential damage to zaporizia is  suicide  territory